ja ich habe mich heute sehr aufgeregt
aber ehrlich gesagt rege ich mich schon
seit wochen auf und zwar seit ist den
status geimpft und ungeimpfter gibt also
bei uns in der gesellschaft kommt es mir
so vor als caps ist gerade so zwei
embleme geimpft und wenn ich ins
restaurant geht zeige ich meinen ausweis
fordern sich geimpft bin dann komme ich
rein muss kein test machen jemand der
nicht hat darf nicht rein auch das
verstehe ich schon nicht aber heute
wollte haben dann die länder für mich so
richtig die krone aufgesetzt und zwar
seien um gfds bei behördlich
angeordneter quarantäne kein krankengeld
mehr bekommt das muss man sich mal
überlegen der standort mit quarantäne an
und dann ist derjenige der die impfung
aus welchem grund auch immer
ausgeschlossen hat für sich zu hause
bleiben und krieg kein geld mehr ich
rufe jetzt hier mit zur solidarität auf
mit den menschen die sich gegen geben
von entschieden haben ich bin auch dafür
dass wir die dass wir uns alle impfen
lassen ich bin selbst doppelt geben ich
habe den schutz hinter mir ich hoffe
dass ich viele viele viele impfen lassen
auch viele die jetzt zu sehen aber wir
müssen euch mit argumenten überzeugen
der staat muss endlich auch wenn
erpresser zu sein das ist ein
spendenaufruf mit spendenaufruf
gemeingut ok und zu solidarität und dass
er stark auf ängste zu erpressen das ist
ja das zu ändern nebeneffekt ist ja
eines hyppiä einzelunternehmer die das
schon sagen dass die belegschaften
gespalten werden es gibt unternehmer
sagen die machen sie das nicht mit das
will ich nicht da habe ich streit im
betrieb deshalb zahle ich den leuten die
dann zu hause bleiben müssen die
lohnfortzahlung zahl ich selber obwohl
ich nicht muss und das ist auch glaube
ich eine gute haltung das wird sich
vielleicht durchsetzen was meinst du wir
haben eine durch solche maßnahmen eine
impfpflicht durch die hintertür ist ja
eine negative sanktionierung und es ist
ja nicht nur so dass jemand in ein
risikogebiet fliegt und zurückkommt wir
hatten das im herbst letzten jahres ist
eines unserer drei kinder an krone
erkrankt wir bekamen am gleichen tag von
den und gesundheitsamt oder von der
zuständigen würden anrufe so sie sind
jetzt alle 14 tage in quarantäne
wir haben uns also nicht in ein anderes
land begeben wir wurden passiv dazu
können die unser kind dann rausschmeißen
sagen wir schleppen das kind weg und
gehen nicht in quarantäne
das finde ich nicht gut trotzdem möchte
ich auch wie du nina sagen ich bin für
impfen und diejenigen die angst vor
möglichen langfrist nebenwirkungen haben
den kann ich nur sagen die kurzfrist und
langfrist wirkung einer echten krone
erkrankung aber massiv wie schlimm
höhere wir sind ja nicht nur opfer wenn
wir uns anstecken wir sind
kopiermaschine werden täter indem wir
andere anstecken also sollte mehr
aufklärung erfolgen wir haben auch zu
viel mist gemacht dass dann leute auch
erzählt haben da bin ich hingefahren
kamen nicht dran musste wieder wegfahren
ich habe da 17 mal in einer woche
angerufen bekam gar keinen termin wir
haben ja auch ganz mies angefangen hat
zu impfen und dann hatten sie einen
termin und jesus der impfstoff ist nicht
da also wir haben sie auch wirklich
nicht gerade zum nachmachen und zum
animieren hier war fällig wie ich habe
sehr lange monate vermissen als mann mit
dem impfausweis irgendwas im praktischen
leben anfangen kann konnte man aber
nicht weil alle restriktionen die
ansonsten für alle galten galten für
dich auch ich habe den im haus aus mit
der vorteil nur anfangs gar nicht damit
anfangen habe ich dann zu hause liegen
lassen aber er ist nicht mein gefühl ist
bei dieser neuen eskalation der staat
schreibt also vor
dass ungeimpfte dieses und jenes nicht
mehr machen dürfen das geht so eine
aufteilung in das war das mitnehmen ich
würde es eher so vor ich habe das gefühl
als ungeimpfte bist du jetzt sozusagen
ein mensch zweiter klasse und das auch
mehr oder weniger schon ein schimpfwort
du ungeimpfter und wer hat es denn zu
verantworten der staat der in zwei
gruppen aufteilen die bösen ungeimpften
und die gruppen kämpften deshalb ich in
der zeit in der ich also sozusagen hier
lebe in deutschland also von anfang an
also seit 50 jahren so noch nicht erlebt
dass der staat sich das heraus nimmt
eine minderheit zu kreieren die er dann
auch gleich selber noch beschimpft und
ich möchte nur eins einen gedanken dabei
tragen so recht kümmern wir uns darum
alle minderheiten und wollen nicht dass
sie stigmatisiert werden und wollen
nicht dass sie ausgegrenzt werden und
wollen nicht dass sie ausgesperrt werden
wir schaffen das und in diesem fall
machen wir es vor unser aller augen mit
also ich selber bin geimpft und aber der
freiheit zu erreichen ja freilich
sagt mir ich möchte nicht in einem land
leben wo der staat sagte boese um gm
versicherung noch was dazu man denn
überhaupt ungeimpfte wurden doch
bestimmt den ungeimpften wohnungen mit
anderen ungeimpften in ungeimpften
vierteln kann man denn da seine kinder
noch also das ist alles für mich so lang
noch erstmals heißt schon die
bundesgesundheits die die
gesundheitsminister dies beschlossen
haben greifen in ein anderes
vertragsverhältnis sein die menschen
sind entweder gesetzlich oder privat
versichert sie haben einen vertrag mit
einer krankenkasse
klar gilt das jetzt für nicht die
erkrankten die erkrankten kriegen ja
ihren schutz und auch ihr krankengeld
aber die familien oder haushalts
bewohner die jetzt passiv zu quarantäne
pflichtigen wären die werden jetzt hier
bestraft es hat ja auch eine
medizinische seite um das mal dazu zu
sagen die geimpften werden im regelfall
auch wenn sie mit infizierten zu tun
haben nicht mehr schwer krank das können
sie nicht mehr im regelfall weil sie
eben geimpft sind das ja der sinn der
sache das heißt sie können mit
ungeimpften umgehen ich bin zweimal
gegen fieber und drittes mal impfen
lassen fürchte mich nicht wenn ich
irgendwo rumlaufe einkaufe denn irgend
einem geschlossenen raum bin ich frage
euch auch nicht ob ihr geimpfte
ungeimpft seit ich habe keine angst mehr
seit ich geimpft bin aber es muss man
hatte eigentlich auch mit ungeimpften
locker herumgehen es nicht mehr
aufklärung statt
gemacht für meine meinung hier auch in
dieser sendung dass ich mir sage
solidarität mit den ungeimpften und der
staat aufwand zu erpressen sagt sie
barsch ich habe meinen arm hingehalten
dann sollen es die anderen auch machen
und das ist für mich diese denkweise die
viele haben die komplett schlimm ist
weil die immer war was auch alles so
dass man geworden ist ich finde es toll
deshalb denkweise entweder oder genauso
wie ich in amerika eben dann die flasche
in die tüte getan habe und genau so wie
ich meinen kindern die windeln gemacht
habe genauso sage ich dann geh ich halt
zum impfen und wenn du nicht gehst das
ist also wenn du deine flasche drei
trägst musste hat dafür riskieren dass
sie mir weggenommen wird also ich finde
sanktionen in irgendeiner form erleben
wir noch dauern in einer vorher kommt
die und aufklärung ja ich finde es viel
wichtiger und absolut nötig dass man
sagt von
den krone erkrankten die nicht geimpft
sind haben wir solche verläufe solche
schwere gerade solche dauer an tagen die
geimpft so dass man einfach so wenn man
das dann hört sagt man ja wie blöd muss
ich eigentlich sein dass ich das nicht
mache und ich wiederhole noch mal die
folgewirkungen nebenwirkungen einer
krone erkrankung sind ein x-fach es
höher als unehrlich ausstellung dauert
wieder dieser der staat muss alles
richten
jeder soll doch also ich glaube dass
jeder besser auf sich selber aufpassen
kann als dass der staat
wenn argumente was helfen würden wäre
das ja wunderbar aber wenn welche sich
für eine bratwurst impfen lassen oder
was auch immer geld finanzieller anreiz
ist das ist doch ich glaube wir seit wir
sollten einfach weiterhin mit argumenten
aber der staat muss auf von ein
erpresser zu sein das war ein ganz
wichtiger punkt von der kassen der geht
er in ein anderes vertragsfrei und wie
für arbeit die nasa ja in der regel die
lohnfortzahlung die ersten sechs wochen
und was geht dir auch grass geht jetzt
in den betrieben los du hast die
spaltung in die betriebe getragen dann
wird natürlich auch gefragt wer ist
überhaupt gerecht ist noch ein aufkleber
und jajaja die kollegen werden sich
gegenseitig fragen
geben dem stehen ja in dem will ich mich
stehen wer als ungeimpft so und das ist
doch kein so etwas ist ja sehr viel weit
entfernt von neben dem will ich nicht
stehen weil der ist und dann wird eine
minderheit eine teilgruppe benannt mit
der man nichts zu tun haben will dabei
müssen wir doch versuchen sozusagen die
gesellschaft zusammenzuführen statt sie
zu spalten das ist ja schon den auftrag
an jedem von uns aber doch erst recht an
den staat gibt ja verrückte nebeneffekte
also in der ddr gab es ja impfpflicht
der staat überhaupt nicht gefragt da
wurde jeder geimpft die leute die das
erlebt haben wissen auch dass sie
dadurch nicht krank geworden sind bis
auf ganz selten ausnahmen so und jetzt
gibt es den reflex weil sie in der ddr
vorgeschrieben war lasse ich mich jetzt
nicht impfen extra das ist also völlig
man eigentlich geholfen hat der sinn ich
aber so ist es halt der staat muss
einfach wieder weniger macht bekommen
und ich finde deswegen mein wird von
klein auf mit einem beigebracht sei
solidarischen ich finde jetzt gar keine
zeit mit das erste mal im leben wo ich
wirklich das gefühl habe ich muss
solidarisch sein und jetzt ist es
plötzlich so als wäre das total
unangebracht aber wir müssen doch jetzt
solidarisch zusammenstehen und die leute
zwei ich mache mein vorschlag wenn wir
das hier wiedersehen in dieser runde
gibt es hier in diesem studio für jeden
der es will eine dritte impfung
oder ich wieder sagt willst du dann
ziehe ich habe
werden
ich
habe mir jetzt meine antikörper testen
lassen sind sehr gering so dass wir mein
arzt empfohlen hat im november die
dritte in botswana und ich würde das
machen gerne auch öffentlich und wir
haben so viele möglichkeiten in der
medizin ich schreibe ja in meinem
aktuellen buch ein ganz langes kapitel
über zukunftsthemen über veränderungen
was wir heute an möglichkeiten haben der
daten vernetzung der verfolgung der
kontakte ich war sieht man vielleicht
vor 32 tagen beim friseur gehe ich hin
will einen zettel aus das elfte mal in
diesem jahr meine handynummer wir müssen
eine mailadresse dass der stift 10 uhr
schnur festgemacht mit dem ich geklaut
wird keine an dem tag monat haben
[Musik]